[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى اخبار الساعه من
العربيه وهذه هي العناوين
رسائل امريكيه الى اوكرانيا ابرزها اظهروا
قليلا من الامتنان
طالبان تعلن دستورها غير المكتوب كل من
يعارض النظام مصيره القتل
انهيار بنك سيليكون فاليثير الاسواق
وامريكا تسعى لتجنب اخطاء 2008
يتعرض لاقصى هجوم من عضو في ادارته
السابقه
اخر المنقلبين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى اخبار الساعه اكد
الجيش الاوكراني انه يحاول كسب الوقت
لتجميع قوات الاحتياطيه ومن ثم شني هجوم
مضاده على روسيا مؤكدا ان هذا الهجوم ليس
بعيدا قال الجيش الاوكراني ان الابطال
الحقيقيين هم الذين يدافعون عن الجبهه
الشرقيه في ضخمه تصريحات تاتي بينما تظهر
شقوق كبيره في التحالف ما بين امريكا
واوكرانيا والسبب ايضا ضخمه
حسب تقرير لصحيفه اعتمد على مقابلات مع
مسؤولين امريكيين فقد اصبحت ضخمه معركه لا
طائل منها بالنسبه للامريكيين الذين يرون
ضروره التوقف عن استنزاف الموارد في مدينه
رمزيه لا تمثل اهميه استراتيجيه من وجهه
النظر الامريكيه تقول بروتوكول نقلا عن
المسؤولين الامريكيين ان اداره غياب للحرب
اصبحت غير مقبوله لاداره بايدن في حين
تنصح امريكا اوكرانيا بضروره تجاوز معركه
بخمو الا انك رفضت واعتبرت ان التخلي عنها
سيؤدي لخساره دونسك باكملها
ايضا يبدو ان الامريكيون قلقون من قدره
اوكرانيا علشان هجوم مضاد بينما تحرق
الاسلحه والذخائر في هذه المعركه كما
ابلغت امريكا اوكرانيا بضروره التوقف عن
مهاجمه القرد حيث ترى واشنطن ان هذا
الهجوم يبعد السلام ويعقد فرص الحل حسب
هذه النصيحه ايضا تتجاهلها اوكرانيا ليكشف
مسؤولا في البيت الابيض لبروتيكو انزعاج
بايدن من عدم اظهار زليسكي لامتنان الكافي
على الدعم الامريكي
المعارك في بخموت تاخذ منحا جديدا باعلان
فاجنر سيطرتها على جنوب المدينه رغم شح
الذخيره الذي بات مشكلا يؤرق الطرفين
المقاومين الاوكران والقوات المواليه
لروسيا وفقا لتقرير صادر عن صحيفه نيوزويك
قوه ستسعى في المرحله المقبله الى اعتماد
استراتيجيه جديده تساعد في تحقيق مكاسب
اكبر وتجنب خسائر محتمله حيث كشفيني انه
سيتم اصلاح المجموعه واعاده هيكلتها
وتصميمها بشكل يضمن تحولها الى منظمه
عسكريه موازيه من النخبه للجيولوجيه خطوه
ستضمن دورا مهما لقوات راجنار في اوكرانيا
التي ستكون مرهونه بموجه جديده من التجنيد
عبر روسيا التي ستتبع لانشاء جيش دي مكون
ايدولوجي يركز بشكل خاص على تجنيد
المقاتلين الشباب وفق مراقبين فان هذه
الخطوه يمكن ان تزيد فجوه التوتر بين
الكريملين وقائد فاجنر الذي يوصل انتقاد
موسكو التي تسعى في كل مره لابطاء المكاسب
العسكريه خصوصا في بخموت التي باتت نقطه
محوريه في القتال حيث ان قوات فاجنر اسهمت
في السيطره على حوالي 50% من المدينه بعد
معارك قويه خاضها الجيش الروسي جنبا الى
جنب مع مجندي مجموعه فاجنر للسيطره على
المنطقه
ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا الجنرال ماركت
مساعد وزير خارجيه الامريكيه الاسبق
للشؤون العسكريه والسياسيه مرحبا بك سيد
مارك هل هناك بالفعل انقسام واختلاف
الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه لاداره العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا ما بين واشنطن
لقد كانت على الدوام سياسه الولايات
المتحده انه بصرف النظر عن القرارات التي
يتخذها الرئيس اللانسكي في اهدافهم من هذه
الحرب فاننا سوف نلتزم بها وسوف نؤيدها
لكن اذا كان الدعم
ليتعلق بمساله القوات العسكريه فهذا سوف
يؤدي الى نتائج مختلفه من حيث الاهداف
التي رسمها لنفسه والغرب من جهه اخرى اذا
كان هناك حاله من الانقسام فهو هذه المره
الاولى التي نسمع عنها فلا بد من وجود اثر
كبير على نتيجه الحرب بالمجمل
سيد مارك يقال في التحليلات الغربيه ان
تمت اختلاف ما بين وجهه نظر فيلنسكي وباي
فيما يتعلق باستمرار العمليات العسكريه
يبدو ان زينسكي يريد احراز نصر عسكري كبير
يحاول به ان يكسر ظهر بوتين في حين ان
امريكا وفقا لتحليلات تريد ان يخرج بوتين
مهزوما ولكن ليس منكسرا للجلوس على مائده
التفاوضات هل هذا حقيقي
اعتقد ان الامر يعتمد على مزيج من الامرين
فالرئيسه
لديه هدف واسع النطاق ويرغب ان يرى اجمال
لمساحه بلاده تتوحد تحت السيطره
الاوكرانيه دون ان يكون هناك اي وجود روسي
واحسب ان هذا الهدف قد يستغرق سنوات طويله
ليتحقق الا اذا كان هناك انهيارًا مفاجئا
لدى القوات الروسيه
وبيد ان
الرئيسكي كان قد عبر عن هذه الطموح
الكبيره فهذا سوف يعني ان هناك حاله من
الشردم فقد نجدها بين الصفوف الاوروبيه
ولابد من وجود توافق بين الرئيسكي ودول
غربيه في مساله التوجه للمفاوضات وازداد
الستار على حاله المعاناه التي تحدث داخل
اوكرانيا طيب روسيا بدات تستخدم الصواريخ
فرط صوتيه وهي تكنولوجيا متقدمه الان يتم
اللجوء اليها وترى التحليلات العسكريه ان
هذا الامر ربما يؤدي الى اكسابها مزيد من
المزايا العسكريه على حساب اوكرانيا كيف
تقيم واشنطن هذا الاستخدام
ان الطريق التي تنظر بها واشنطن الى هذا
الامر هي
انها تدرك امرا الروس لديهم
مخزون بات قليلا من الاسلحه ومن الصواريخ
فرط الصوتيه ثانيا فان الدفاع الجوي داخل
اوكرانيا سوف
يصبح اكثر كفاءه بحيث يمنعهم من الحقول
دون وقوع دمار شامل والنقطه الثالثه التي
يجدر بنا ان نقر بها هي ان الشعب
الاوكراني بعينه لن يغيروا من عزيمتهم في
مواجهه تلك الاسلحه وصواريخ فرق الصوتيه
كما حدث في الحرب العالميه الثانيه عندما
قصه اقامت بريطانيا بالتعرض لقصف كبير من
القوات النازيه لكن عزم بريطانيا انذاك لم
يهز
ورغم ما قام به الديكتاتور هتلر في سن هذه
الهجمات
فهذا الامر لم يجعل الشعب البريطاني ان
يتخلى عن عزيمته واعمل ان يقوم الشعب
الاوكراني باتخاذ نفس المنحى الجنرال
ماركه مساعد وزير خارجيه الامريكيه الاسبق
للشؤون العسكريه وسياسيه من واشنطن تحياتي
وفي جديد حادثه التفجير خطوط انابيب نوت
ستريم مفاجات باتت اصابعه الاتهام تتجه
نحو اوكرانيا بعد ان كانت تشير الى روسيا
وذلك حسب تقييم لوكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه تم الكشف عنه قبل نحو
اسبوع هذه الاتهامات لاوكرانيا قد تصبح
عاملا رئيسيا في اجراءات التحكيم التي
تقدر بمليارات الدولارات والتي رفعتها
شركات الطاقه الاوروبيه ضد شركه الغاز
الروسيه العملاقه حيث زعمت شركه اوروبيه
ان فشل شركه
متعاقد عليها في الغاز الطبيعي منذ الصيف
الماضي تسبب في اضرار كبيره بالطبع لها من
خلال اجبارها على شراء غاز اغلى بكثير من
الصوف لكن خبراء القانون والمحللين يقولون
ان الانفجارات التي جعلت خطوط الانابيب
غير صالحه للعمل يمكن ان تساعد في تعزيز
قضيه جازبروم خاصه اذا ثبت ان جماعه
مواليه لاوكرانيا وليست الروسيه هي التي
تقف وراءها ومع ذلك فالقضيه ليست مباشره
لان جاسكوم خفضت التدفقات الخاصه بها قبل
الانفجارات التي جعلت الخطوط الانابيب في
النهايه غير قابله للتشغيل وردا على هذه
التقارير الغربيه التي تتهم اوكرانيا
بالتورط بتفجير خطوط انابيب نورد ستريم
وصف وزير خارجيه الاوكرانيبا هذه التقارير
الاعلاميه بانها اجراء منسق مشيرا الى ان
السلطات الاوكرانيه تريد مناقشه الوضع حول
خطوط انابيب الغاز مع وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه
وبالعوده مشاهدينا الى عمليه التخريب التي
شهدتها خطوط انابيب نوردا ستريم كانت مجله
الالمانيه كشفت الطريقه التي تم بها تفجير
خط نقل الغاز الذي يربط روسيا والمانيا
حسب المصدر فان التفجير الذي وقع في ستمبر
الماضي نفذه فريق من الغواصين يتحدثون لغه
تبدو مثل البولنديه او التشيكيه انطلقوا
من يختن مؤجر يصل طوله الى 15 متر ويحمل
اسم اندروميدا وتم متابعه مسار هذا اليخت
في بحر البلطيق بدءا من ميناء روسو الروسي
في رستوك بالمانيا في السادس من سبتمبر
2022 ثم عبوره لجزيره روجن الالمانيه
وصولا الى جزيره كريستيانسو الدنماركيه
على مقربه من مكان الانفجار في السادس
والعشرين من الشهر ذاتي تشير التقديرات ان
مئات الكيلو جرامات من المتفجرات قد
استخدمت في تفجيره خط انابيب الغاز ولن
يركز خبراء على وزن المواد المتفجره فحسب
لان الغواصين المحتملين كانوا في حاجه الى
معدات اخرى حتى تساعدهم على التنفس تحت
الماء اضافه الى تجهيزات معقده واذا هذه
النقاط رجح الخبراء فرديه ان تكون مركبه
بحريه اخرى قد ساعدت اليخت من اجل انجاز
مهمته وذكر ان احد افراد طاقم اليخ كان
يحمل جواز سفر بلغاريا وهو جواز مزور في
حين يواصل المحققون الالمان جهودهم لتحديد
الجنسيه باقي الضالعين في التفجير كما
يدرسون ايضا اتهام حكومه الدوله ما
بالمسؤوليه عما وقع
[موسيقى]
ابدت وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه استغربها
من تصريحات الولايات المتحده التي نفت
فيها وجود اتفاقا لتبادل السجناء بين
امريكا وايران واكدت ان هذا الاتفاق موجود
بالفعل ولا يجوز استخدامه للالعاب
السياسيه كان البيت الابيض قد نفى تصريحات
وزير خارجيه ايران بشان التواصل الاتفاق
التبادل سجناء بين امريكا وايران وقل
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت
الابيض جون كيربي قال ان هذه التصريحات
كاذبه واضفت ان المسؤولين الايرانيين لا
يترددون دائما في اختلاق الاحداث مشيرا
الى ان هذه المزاعم الكاذبه ستزيد حزن
عائلات الامريكيين المحتجزين لدى ايران
كان وزير الخارجيه الايراني اعلن التواصل
الاتفاق مبدئي لتبادل السجناء مع واشنطن
وقال ان طهران تسعى لتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق في
اسرع وقت ممكن وكانت مصادر العربيه ايضا
اكدت وجود صفقه بين واشنطن وطهران تتضمن
اطلاق ايران ثلاث رهائن امريكيين مقابل
افراز واشنطن عن اموال لطهران مجمده في
العراق واليابان وكوريا
ما دعر خصوص نواصل تبادل الرسائل مع
الجانب الامريكي فيما يتعلق فقط بتخفيف
العقوبات فيما يتعلق بتبادل الاسرى
الحاليين بين ايران والولايات المتحده فقد
توصلنا خلال الايام الماضيه الى اتفاق اذا
صارت الامور على ما يرام في الجانب
الامريكي اعتقد اننا سنشهد تبادل الاسرى
في المستقبل القريب
[موسيقى]
ومن اخبار الساعه قال وزير التعليم العالي
بحكومه طالبان ندى محمد نديم انه يجب قتل
كل من يخالف الحكومه واضاف ان من يزعزع
النظام بالنطق او بالقلم او بالافعال يجب
قتله
النظام
كل من يسعى لزعزعه استقرار النظام ان كان
بالنطق او القلم او الافعال فان جميع
هؤلاء يعتبرون من البغات ويجب قتلهم
ما في لقاء مع كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه بمجلس النواب لسان ان
الامريكيه قال انه طلب من وزاره الخارجيه
عددا كبيرا من الوثائق المتعلقه بانسحاب
اداره بايدن من افغانستان ومنح نائب ولايه
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه بمجلس النواب
الوزراء مهله حتى السادس والعشرين من
يناير للرد الجمهوريون كانوا قد تعهدوا
بعد سيطرتهم على مجلس النواب في
الانتخابات المصريه لعام 2022
بمحاسبه اداره بيض على تداعيات الانسحاب
الفوضوي لجميع القوات الامريكيه من
افغانستان صيف 2021
مشاهد تعود بنا الى عام 2021 عن الخروج
الامريكي الفوضوي حين سقطت كابول وصعدت
طالبان وانهار الجيش الافغاني سريعا
ليتحول الى مشروع تجنيد مغر للقوى الكبرى
بقوام يتالف من 300 الف التحق معظم من كان
يحمي البلاد باخطر الجماعات الارهابيه
الموجوده في افغانستان قسم صغير واصل مع
طالبان واخرون حصلوا على صفقات جيده مع
قوه فاجنر الروسيه للقتال في اوكرانيا
عمليا ليس التركه المعدات العسكريه
الامريكيه التي تقدر بالملايين هي اكبر
خطا خلفته امريكا وراءها بل الضباط
السابقون في المخابرات والجنود وافراد
الشرطه الذين حظوا بافضل التدريبات على
ايدي القوات الامريكيه لمده 20 عاما
هؤلاء المجندون الجدد هم من اخرج تنظيم
داعش خراسان من ظلمات اختباوا فيها منذ
عام 2015 حين اضعفتهم الهزائم المتكرره مع
طالبان
وجلبوا خبره جمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
وتقنيات الحرب وعززوا من قدره التنظيم على
تحدي تفوق طالبان خلال اقل من 18 شهرا
ولعل هذا مكانه ترمي اليه الولايات
المتحده خلف فوضى مستمره وقوى مناوئه
تحسبا من توسع طالبان غير مرغوب به وفقا
للحركه يقول مسؤولون ان التنظيم يغذي
قوامه من انهيار الوضع الاقتصادي يغري
المنتسبين الجدد بالحمايه من طالبان
ويمنحهم مبالغ نقديه كبيره
يظل التنظيم اهم تحد تواجهه طالبان بعد
تبنيه عشرات الهجمات الارهابيه التي اسفرت
عن مقتل المئات منذ السقوط الفوضوي كرم
حناوي العربيه
ولدينا في اخبار الساعه بعد قليل
في ولايه جيفنج ثالثه كرئيس الصين وجوه
الحكومه الجديده من الصقور
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مراجحه مصادر المطلعه ان تظهر
الحكومه الامريكيه اعلاما جوهريا لدعم
الودائع في بنك سيليكون فالي الذي انهار
للحيوله دون اتساع نطاق التداعيه وفقا
للمصادر فان مسؤولي اداره الرئيس الامريكي
عملوا على تقييم انهيار البنك وهي الاكبر
منذ الازمه الماليه لعام 2008 مع التركيز
بشكل خاص على قطاع راس المال والبنوك
الاقليميه
كانت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه قالت ان
الاقتصاد الامريكي والنظام المالكي ظلام
امنا واشارت الى ان انهيار سيليكون بالي
كبنك يعتبر صادم ومقلق لكنها لفتت ايضا
الى ان مرور احد البنوك بازمه لا يعني
بالضروره ان بقيه البنوك ستعاني وان
الاداره الامريكيه تسعى لعدم انتقال
مشكلات البنك سيلفون باليه الى بنوك اخرى
هذا وقال في بريطانيا وزير الماليه جيرميه
ان انهيار بنك لن يشكل خطرا عن النظام
المالي في البلاد لكنه سيكون خطيرا على
قطاعات محدده
اعتقد ان اول شيء يجب قوله هو ان محافظ
بنكي انجلترا المركزي قد اوضح تماما انه
لا توجد مخاطر منهجيه على نظامنا المالي
لذلك يجب طمانه الناس على هذا الاساس ولكن
هناك خطر جسيم على تقنيتنا وقطاعات علوم
الحياه والعديد منها يتعامل مع هذا البنك
الذي لم يسمع به معظم الناس
الاقتصادي دكتور ناصر السعيدي وزير
الاقساط والتجاره الاسبق ونائب اول حاكم
مصرف لبنان الاسبق مرحبا بك معالي الوزير
على شاشه العربيه هناك تطمينات لكن حتى
الان لا تبدو في الافق خطط واضحه ومتدرجه
للتعامل مع الودائع مع حقوق المودعين ما
الذي سيحدث
[موسيقى]
المحفظه كانت بسندات طويله الاجل
دفاع الفوائد خلال المرحله 6 شهور السنه
الماضيه ادت لخسارات كبيره بهالمحفظه وصلت
تقريبا لراس مال المصرف لها السبب صار في
الانهيار وقت المعدوم موضعين عرفوا انه
فيها الخسارات الضخمه اللي منا محققه
فسحبوا وضيعهم طيب بالعوده الى 2800 يتذكر
الجميع هذه الازمه الكبيره التي كانت
مرتبطه بمؤسسه واشنطن والتي ادت الى
تداعيات اقتصاديه خطيره ما هي الضمانات ان
هناك تعلم من دروس الماضي وان هذا لن
يتكرر مجددا
بالحقيقه طبعا المسؤولين هيجدوا انه ما في
مخاطر على النظام المصرفي لكن لازم نلاحظ
انه مشاكل اس بي بي ممكن كمان تكون موجوده
بغير مصاري المصارف الامريكيه عندها
خسارات غير
بالمحافظ تبعيتها بحدود 620 ملي
ار دولار هذا رقم كبير طبعا المصارف
الكبيره مش هتتاثر
لكن المصارف الصغيره المصارف الاقليميه
على انواع
مصاريف اللي
[موسيقى]
معرضه
معرضه لخطر هل كانت المصارف بامريكا او
كمان ببريطانيا او حتى بالصيني لانه اس بي
بي كمان عنده استثمار عبر وجوده بالصين
وبريطانيا سوف افتكر هون المخاطر الكبرى
طيب يقال ان تدخل مشتري في هذا التوقيت
ربما يكون حل لهذه الازمه خاصه ان ايلون
ماسك ترك الباب مفتوحا لامكانيه ان يقوم
بشراء هذا البنك هل يمكن ان يكون هذا حلا
بالفعل وهل يقدم ماسك على شراء هذا البنك
خاصه ان صفقه تويتر يعني 44 مليارا كان
كبيره بالنسبه له وليست هينه
طبعا مصلحه مستثمر انه ينتظر لانه بيقدر
يحصل على سعر افضل فافتكر اول مرحله بكره
حيصير في اعلان من الفجر والخزينه
الامريكيين انه حيكون في تدخل من قبل
الفجر لمده سيوله لاي مؤسسه او حتى
المودعين اللي معرضين لمشاكل اس بيبيه
افتكر هيدي اول مرحله بعدين خلال الاسبوع
القادم ممكن وقتها يبرز مستثمر لكن مثل ما
ذكرت يعني مصلحه اي مستثمر انه ينتظر لانه
بيحصل على سعر افضل من مؤسسه الضمان
الودائيه لليوم هي حاطه ايدها على المسرح
حضرتك الاقتصاديه الكبيره
وقع ان يشهد الاقتصاد العالمي ازمه كما
حدثت من قبل في تقديرك الشخصي النسبه كم
عالميه لكن في خطر على القطاع المصرفي
الاصغر بامريكا يعني صغير بامريكا وربما
كمان ببريطانيا وبعض المصارف مثل كريدي
سويس اللي عم بيعاني اليوم من بعض المشاكل
العالمي يعني لا يتحمل كل هذه التداعيات
الكبيره لازمه متعدده دكتور ناصر الصعيدي
وزير الاقتصاد والتجاره الاسبق ونائبه اول
حاكم مصر في لبنان الاسبق تحياتي
[موسيقى]
يتوجه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الى
الولايات المتحده للقاء الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن والرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي من
اجل الانتهاء من تفاصيل صفقه الغواصات
النوويه لاستراليا وياتي ذلك بموجب
التحالف اوكس الثلاثي الذي يهدف لمواجهه
الوجود العسكريه المتنامي للصين في منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادر
ومع تزايد المخاوف من ان الصين قد تشن
غزوا على تايوان في السنوات المقبله يعمل
الجيش الامريكي على توسيع نطاق وجوده في
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وتعزيز قدرات حلفائه
في المنطقه ايضا مفتاح استراتيجيه رضع
الصين عن اي تحركات عدوانيه هو التركيز
المتزايد على تعزيز قدرات الجيوش
الامريكيه والجيوش المتحالفه على العمل
بشكل فعال معا وزير الدفاع الاستراليه قال
انه يريد ان تصل درجه التنسيق الى حد
تبادل المعدات العسكريه والتي يقول خبراء
الدفاع انها يمكن ان تتضمن استخداما
متكررا للاسلحه والمعدات وامدادات الذخيره
لبعضهم البعض وتنسيق اللوجيسيات وسلاسل
التوريد بكفاءه اكبر الولايات المتحده
تخطط ايضا لزياده وجودها في شمال استراليا
وفي نقطه انطلاق محتمله لاي صراع في
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ حيث يتدرب مشاه
البحريه الامريكيه مع الجيش الاسترالي
وتعليقا على الخطوه الراميه الى اندماج
الجيشين الامريكي والاسرائيلي قال صحيفه
الصينيه التي تديرها الدوله ان ذلك سيؤدي
الى ان يصبح الجيش الاسترالي مجرد عنصر في
اطار خطه لمن وصفتهم بالمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين الامريكيين الذين يدعون
الاحتفاظ بالسياده على جيشهم
لكن الصين لا تبدو انها تتجه للتهدئه
بالمناسبه يظهر ذلك جليا مع بدايه الولايه
الثالثه للرئيس جيفنج الذي غير وجوه
وزارته الهادئه باخرين من معسكر الصقور
فمثلا اليوم تم تاكيد تعيين الجنرال كوزير
جديد للدفاع في البلاد وهو من المدرجين
على قوائم العقوبات الامريكيه بسبب شراء
اسلحه روسيه ويذكر ان وزير الدفاع الصيني
الجديد هو من رواد تحديث جيش التحرير
الشعبي الصيني ايضا وزير الخارجيه المعين
حديثا اظهر تحولا في وجد دبلوماسيه
الهادئه ووزير الخارجيه السابقين فوزير
الخارجيه الجديد في اول مؤتمر صحفي له قبل
اسبوع قال ان الصراع والمواجهه مع
الولايات المتحده امر لما فر منه اذا لم
تغيره واشنطن سياسته
[موسيقى]
وزير الدفاع الصيني الجديد عهد قد ينبئ
بتوترات مع الولايات المتحده
صحيح انه يطابق الصفات المفترضه للحزب
الشيوعي الصيني وحظي بموافقه اعلى هيئه
تشريعيه في الصين لكنه مدرج في قائمه
العقوبه الامريكيه منذ عام 2018
حيث تتهمه واشنطن بالتعاون العسكري مع
موسكو حينما كان يتراس مديريه الاسلحه
علما بانه شغل منصب رئيس قسم تطوير
المعدات وقاد قوه الدعم الاستراتيجي للجيش
الصيني وامضى ثلاثه عقود من الزمن في مركز
شيت شانج لاطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه ما يعني
ان الصعود ليشانغ فو يعكس تطورا غير مسبوق
لمؤسسه الفضاء
اذ ستواصل بكين منح الاولويه للفضاء في
اجنده ولايه شيجين بينج الثالثه وسيمثل
وجود وزير الدفاع الجديد عمل المحفزا
لاستحداث تكنولوجيات قتاليه ينافس بها
امريكا
[موسيقى]
بعد انتهاء انتخابات التجديد النصفيه في
نوفمبر الماضي بدا الطريق الى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه لعام 2020
يرسم مساره الوجهه لا تزال ضبابيه وسط
اعلان البعض عزمهم حوض غمار السباق الى
البيت الابيض فيما ينتظر عدد من المرشحين
اللحظه المناسبه لكن اللافت الصراع الدائر
داخل البيت الواحد للدقه اكثر بين اعضاء
الحزب الجمهوري الذين تعوا اصواتهم واحدا
تلو الاخر انتقادا وتحديدا للرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب وفي اشد
الانتقادات حتى الان للترامب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق الذي قال ان
التاريخ سيحاسب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ترامب على دوره في الهجوم على مبنى
الكونجرس في السادس من يناير
وفي التفاصيل انتقادات ماكس ليست وليده
الساعه وتعود لحادثه الكبد فتعود ليوم
اقتحم الالاف من انصار مبنى الكونجرس في
محاوله لمنع ماركنس من التصديق على نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2020 والتي
خسرها ترامب كان مايك بينز داخل مبنى
الكابيتون لكنه كانت مهمته الدستوريه
كنائب رئيس هو التصديق على نتائج
الانتخابات وهو ما رفضه انصار ترامب الذين
هاتفوا يشنقوا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن داخل الحزب الجمهوريه في الولايات
المتحده لم يكن مايك بينس وحده في وجه
الانتقادات
فحاكمه ولايه صوت كارولينا سابقين انتقدت
في وقت سابق في الهجوم على مبنى الكابيتون
من قبل انصاره وقالت ان افعاله منذ يوم
الانتخابات سيحكم عليها التاريخ وبقسوه
الى ذلك ايضا وجه انتقادات مبطنه الى
رئيسه السابق مجادلا بان البلاد بحاجه الى
قاده جديد لا يقضون وقتهم بالتفكير في
تويتر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
دكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه مساء الخير دكتور وليد
دكتور الى البيت الابيض لابد ان يبدا
بالهجوم على
هكذا يظن معظم المرشحين الجمهوريين
الاخرين يعني او بالاحرى البرايمريز يعني
الجوله الاولى هي بين المرشحين جمهوريين
لا يمكن ان يكونوا مرشحين وان لا ينتقلوا
بعضهم البعض لكي
يحققوا بعض الانتصارات ولكن لو سمحت لي ان
اوضح الصوره والمعادله بتاثير انا معظم
هؤلاء المرشحين الذين ذكروا من مايك بانس
الى
السفير السابقه في الامم المتحده الى
الاخرين المسيسين يعني كان عندهم علاقات
سياسيه ليس لديهم القدره الشعبيه بعد يعني
ربما
عناوينهم ومسؤولياتهم كنائب رئيس سابق قد
توحي للبعض من خارج المعادله انه قد يكون
له حظ انا باعتقادي هنالك شخصيه واحده في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من ضمن الحزب
الجمهوري ولكن بشروط قادره هذه الشخصيه ان
تواجه الرئيس ترامب وهي لم تتكلم حتى الان
لا من قريب ولا من بعيد وهو كما هو ربما
معلوم لديكم حاكم ولايه فلوريدا ارون
ديسانس طيب هناك تساؤلات لماذا خرج
عن صمته كان يبدو محافظا او متحفظا في
فترات سابقه هل هذا الاعلان اليوم هو
تمهيد لقوله الانتخابات
دون شك هو سوف يخوض هذه الانتخابات ونوضح
شيئا ما في السياسات الداخليه الامريكيه
كما تعلمناها
معركه رئاسه الجمهوريه في الانتخابات
الداخليه للاحزاب ليست بالضروره ان هنالك
ايمان بالنجاح في نهايه المطاف هذه تعزز
موقف هذه الشخصيه بالحزب الجمهوري كما
راينا في الانتخابات السابقه الثلاثه يعني
البعض منهم يعرف انه لن يصل ولكن هذا يؤدي
الى تقويه هذه الشخصيه لامور اخرى البعض
منهم يعرف انه لن يصل ولكن اذا خاض هذه
المعركه سوف يعطيه المنتصر يعني المرشح
النهائي للحزب موقعا مثلا في الحكومه
الاتيه وهذا ما رايناه مثلا مع وزيرين على
الاقل الذين رافقوا ترامب في 2016 كانوا
هم يعني هم كانوا يسابقونه وبالتالي
بنهايه المطاف اصبحوا وزراء
في بودكاست الاخير لميشيل اوباما قالت او
افصحت انها بكت في المحطه الاخيره في
طائره الرئاسه وانها كانت تشعر بالحزن
الشديد يوم حفل التنصيب منذ ذلك التاريخ
لا يبدو ان الحزب الديمقراطي قد عمل بجديه
على افراز بدائل جديده للانتخابات القادمه
هل هذا صحيح ام ان وجود بيض في البيت
الابيض كرئيس ديمقراطي حتى اللحظه هو
العائق
هنالك مشاكل كثيره عند الجمهوريين تكلمنا
عنهم وسوف نتكلم ايضا عن هذا الموضوع ولكن
بالنسبه للديمقراطيين نوعيه المشاكل
مختلفه صحيح الكلام انه ليس هنالك من
قيادات شابه تتحدى الجيل القديمه تصوري
الرئيس بايدن من الحزب الديمقراطي المفروض
ان يمثل القواعد الشعبيه والشبابيه الى ما
هنالك هو عمر متقدم جدا خاصه اذا تم اعاده
انتخابه وبالتالي فالسؤال هو لماذا لا
تتحرك القيادات الوسطى في الحزب
الديمقراطي لتصل الى هذا المستوى وتتحول
هي كما تحول باراك اوباما في 2004 اذكر
خطابه هو الذي اطلقه للانتخابات النهائيه
يبدو انه الاله السياسيه التي تنتج
المرشحين عند الحزب الديمقراطي هي قلقه من
ان تخاطر باي شخصيه شابه اخرى المصالح
كبيره بشكل الان هي تريد ان يعاد انتخاب
الرئيس بايدن مره ثانيه وبعد ذلك ربما
تعود الى القواعد الشبابيه اكثر ولكن لا
تريد المخاطره في هذه المرحله دكتور وليد
فارس الغدير في سياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
تحياتي دكتور
ولدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه على شاشه
العربيه
ايطاليا تقول ان اوروبا مهدده بسبعمائه
الف مهاجر ينتظرون فرصه للهروب من ليبيا
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه من العربيه مستمره في
ايطاليا كشف عضو مجلسا وبالايطالي تونسي
فوتي ان معلومات استخباراتيه تشير الى
وجود ما يقرب من 700 الف مهاجر كثير منهم
في معسكرات الاعتقال الليبيه ينتظرون فرصه
الانطلاق عن طريق البحر نحو ايطاليا فمنذ
بدايه هذا العام حتى العاشر من مارس وصل
حوالي
17,600 شخص منهم بضعه الاف نزلوا الى
الموانئ الايطاليه في الايام القليله
الماضيه بدوره قال خبر السواحل الايطالي
انه انقذ اكثر من الف مهاجر قباله السواحل
الجنوبيه للبلاد في الايام الاخيره فيما
وصل 100 اخرون الى جزيره مندوسوا
الايطاليه الصغيره جنوب صقليه بعد
انطلاقهم من تونس حسب السلطات
وفي اليونان ومع تصاعد الغضب من حادث سكه
حديد سكك حديديه هو الاكثر دمويه في
البلاد نظم الالاف من المتظاهرين احتجاجات
جديده مما زاد الضغط على الحكومه حيث تجمع
المتظاهرون في اثينا امام البرلمان ملوحين
بلافتات كتب عليها لن ننسى لن نسامح
وسنصبح صوت كل الموتى بدورها قالت الشرطه
ان اكثر من 8000 متظاهر تجمعوا خارج
البرلمان
وفي هولندا اغلق الالاف من النشطاء
الحمايه البيئيه طريقا رئيسا في احتجاج
جديد دون ان يحصلوا على تصريح بتنظيمه
وتحول الاحتجاج الى اعمال عنف بعد ان
اطلقت الشرطه خراطيم المياه على
المتظاهرين الذين رفضوا مغادره الطريق مما
اعاقه حركه المرور داخل وخارج المدينه
الهولنديه
شكرا وليس بعيدا عن اخبار الرياضه اشعل
تغريده جاري لانكر مقدم البرامج الرياضيه
في قناه بي بي سي جدلا كبيرا في بريطانيا
بعدما شبه مشروع قانون قوارب الهجره غير
القانوني الذي اعلنت عنه وزيره الداخليه
شبهه بقوانين المانيا النازيه اوقفت
لاينكر عن تقديم برمجه الشهير الامر الذي
ادى لانسحابه موظفين من العمل وردود افعال
غاضبه داخل وخارج المؤسسه الاعلاميه
التفاصيل مع الزميله عروبا عبد الحق
تحول الجدل الحاصل حول مشروع قانون قوارب
الهجره غير النظاميه في بريطانيا من
مناقشه لمضمون القانون الى خلافات شكليه
تناول التعابير اعلاميه واسقاطات تاريخيه
فتغريده الذي يقدم برامج على قناه بي بي
سي والتي شبه فيها قانون الهجره بتلك خلال
ايام المانيا النازيه فجرت معركه كانت
تطويق اليها تيارات بريطانيا المتصارعه في
البدايه اوقف جاري
لينكجه فانسحب العديد من الصحفيين من
اعمالهم في المؤسسه اشتعلت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ولا يبدو ان هناك تهدئه من
داعمي الذين هددوا بالانسحاب من المؤسسه
بسبب ما يقولون انه انتهاك لحريه التعبير
[تصفيق]
تجاوز المقبول في تعليقاته اعتبر اخرون ان
قرار بي بي سي قد يحد من قدره الناس على
ابداء رايهم في قرارات الحكومه من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
اعلن سلطات بيروح على تطورات البلاد حيث
تسبب اعصار ياكو في هطول امطار غزيره
وتدمير مئات المنازل وحدوث فيضانات كبيره
في المناطق الشماليه للبلاد ادت الى مقتل
سته اشخاص على الاقل
[موسيقى]
والختام مع عناوين وابرز عناوين اخبار
الساعه رسائل امريكيه الى اوكرانيا ابرزها
اظهروا قليلا من الامتنان
[موسيقى]
طالبان تعلن دستورها غير المكتوب كل من
يعارض النظام مصيره القتل
انهيار بنك سيليكون بالي يثير ذره الاسواق
وامريكا تسعى لتجنب اخطاء 2008
و ترامب يتعرض لاقصى هجوم من عضو في
ادارته سابقه انه مايك فينس اخر المنقلين
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]